economía en france 24 me acompaña en el
estudio daniela blandón daniela buena
noche bienvenida en chile y ashley el
segundo retiro anticipado de las
pensiones o la radón muy buenas noches
recordemos que el gobierno de sebastián
piñera siempre se ha opuesto al retiro
anticipado porque teme que el sistema
quede financiado para atender las
futuras jubilaciones sin embargo
presentó su propio proyecto de retiro
cuando vio que el presentado por la
oposición iba por buen camino aunque
ambos eran casi iguales pues se
permitirá entonces un retiro en dos
cuotas de hasta el 10 por ciento de los
ahorros en un proceso que inicia a
partir del lunes próximo se estima que
el mínimo retirar es de unos 2300
dólares y el máximo unos 5.700 y quienes
tengan rentas mensuales de más de dos
mil dólares serán sujetos a pagar
impuestos en un primer retiro aprobado
en julio raúl nueve de los 11 millones
de afiliados retiraron más de 17 mil
millones de dólares
daniela de una noticia positiva porque
el desempleo en eeuu bajó en el mes de
noviembre
es agridulce de la noticia porque ha
venido bajando y ya está en una tasa del
6 7 % cuando en abril se había disparado
al 14 7 % pero aunque parece que hay una
mejoría lo que muestran las estadísticas
es que la creación de plazas laborales
están niveles muy bajos en noviembre se
incorporaron apenas 245 mil plazas
laborales menos de la mitad que en
octubre y la cifra más baja desde que
empezó la pandemia y es que de los 21,2
millones de empleos perdidos entre marzo
y abril se han recuperado poco menos de
12 millones o sea que todavía hay más de
9 millones pendiente agridulce como
usted dijo pero continuamos en ese país
o porque la cámara baja en la cámara
baja avanza una ley para despenalizar el
uso de la marihuana a nivel federal ya
lo aprobaron una cámara baja falta el
senado
raúl pues lo aprobó la cámara de
representantes lo difícil ahora será que
lo haga el senado porque es de mayoría
republicana ya que el proyecto es
avalado en gran parte por demócratas
desde que fue incluida como sustancia
controlada en 1970 15 estados y el
distrito de columbia ha legalizado el
uso recreativo de la marihuana los
últimos cinco entre ellos new yersey y
arizona lo hicieron en los referendos
simultáneos de las pasadas elecciones
del 3 de noviembre desde entonces las
empresas dedicadas a esta industria en
esas zonas están volando en la bolsa a
raúl la acción por ejemplo de aurora que
una vez más que se duplicó en el último
mes hay otra que se llama canopy graus
que subió más del 40 por ciento y crees
collapse lo hizo en 43 por ciento y mi
dato del cierre de esta noticia es que
las ventas de marihuana alcanzaron en
niveles récord el pasado fin de semana
de acción de gracias'
así de saunier a nosotros entonces ahora
cambiamos de información porque francia
amenaza a completar un evento
acuerdo post éxito si una semana más de
negociaciones y todavía no hay acuerdo y
queda menos de un mes para que el reino
unido se vaya de la unión europea la
semana fue bastante intensa raúl los
negociadores reunidos en un centro de
conferencias en londres casi que ni
salieron del resisto y se alimentaron a
punta de domicilios de pizza y de
sándwiches para no interrumpir los
diálogos la falta de consenso allana el
camino para una ruptura desordenada y
ahora la clave no es tanto si hay
acuerdo o no sino qué clase de acuerdo
es francia que es el país que más se
beneficia de la pesca de aguas
británicas ya ha amenazado con vetarlo
escuchemos
y francia como todos sus socios se tiene
poder de veto por lo que realizaremos
nuestra propia evaluación de esta
propuesta de acuerdo si existe se lo
debemos a los franceses se lo debemos a
nuestros pescadores y a otros sectores
económicos
daniela indicadores como cierre la
semana muy bien raúl wall street' del
cerro con triples récords los índices
dow jones nasdaq y standard en pues
alcanzaron cifras nunca antes vistos
las bolsas europeas se subieron
impulsadas por el precio del petróleo
brent madrid él rompió máximo desde
marzo y en latinoamérica la bolsa de sao
paulo subió casi un 3 por ciento y
alcanzó niveles pre pandemia para
finalizar que nos trae como cifra el día
3 mil 45 por ciento es la inflación
acumulada del año en su país venezuela
raúl hasta noviembre según el parlamento
controlado por la oposición el dato
oficial del gobierno más reciente es muy
diferente y tiene dos meses de retraso
éste habla de una inflación de 800 44
por ciento los precios de la canasta
familiar han subido tanto que para
comprar un dólar se necesita un millón
de bolívar lamentable pero no
sorprendente gracias a daniele ustedes
también gracias continuó
[Música]